ciao a tutti allora ogni anno ogni mese
ogni giorno che passa speriamo sempre
più tempo davanti al computer
davanti al telefono davanti al software
quindi interagiamo per ore ore tutti i
giorni con una serie di un mondo
virtuale fatidico nei fatti di metafore
dobbiamo e possiamo rispettare una serie
di regole che vengono definite dai
designer dai creatori dei software che
noi usiamo tutti i giorni e interagiamo
con quella nuova tecnologia tramite un
touch screen tra una tastiera un mouse e
non usiamo il nostro corpo appieno
insomma fatto che noi abbiamo due
braccia due gambe
possiamo saltare possiamo fare sapere
cose e quindi da qualche anno e le siamo
a questa parte ha preso piede tantissimo
questo fenomeno di appunto realtà
aumentata
allora cos'è la realtà aumentata e tutta
quella serie di tecnologie della serie
di invenzioni che cercano di far uscire
la tecnologia dal dal computer dal
telefono e cercare di integrarla nè la
realtà che ci circonda
quindi insomma siamo tutti credo
conosciamo google gas fino a che ha
insomma il fenomeno virale di
quest'estate dei pokémon go gente che
corre il giro per le strade e cercheremo
astri insomma questa diciamo tendenza di
cercare di tornare nel mondo reale però
un reale un po modificato un po si spera
migliorato tramite tante l'uso di nuove
tecnologie
io tre anni fa ho avuto questa idea di
cercare di trasformare ogni oggetto
attorno a noi in uno strumento musicale
allora perché perché anche nella musica
quando si tratta di nuove tecnologie
la faccenda non cambia noi stiamo stiamo
dietro uno schermo interagiamo con la
musica tramite la tecnologia con una
tastiera con un mouse muovendo una
manopola muovendo con controller e
quindi mi sono detto e poi si deve
applicare questo questo questa idea del
la realtà aumentata alla musica e o
appunto creato questo piccolo sensore
allora avuto questa idea intanto si
chiama si chiama play the world ha un po
l'idea abbiamo creato questo sensore
mischiava mogis a quello qui che che non
fa altro che diciamo riconoscere le
vibrazioni che noi facciamo sull'oggetto
il quale lo appiccichiamo convertirle in
un segnale che entra appunto in un
telefono oppure in un computer e
trasforma tutte le mie azioni in musica
in tempo reale quindi faccio vedere un
piccolo video poi vi spiego di cosa si
tratta
grazie a tutti allora come funziona sta
cosa
allora c'è un c'è un sensore che appunto
diciamo rileva tutte le vibrazioni che
noi facciamo quando interagiamo quell
oggetto fisico
questo oggetto fisico può essere un
albero fosse una bicicletta può essere
forse le tavole della nostra cucina può
essere un aeroplano intero un progetto
che abbiamo fatto un anno fa e
trasformano questo segnale è questa
questo movimento in un segnale elettrico
che entra in una app dove c'è un
algoritmo verità hanno fatto 4 up finora
ma il principio è sempre lo stesso ci
sono queste due componenti una
componente di siamo dedicata al
controllo e una delegata al suono
allora partiamo la città al suono e il
modo in cui diciamo vengono generati in
suoni qui è appunto basato sul concetto
si chiama sintesi modelli fisici vuol
dire
immaginatevi quando noi studiamo una
chitarra per esempio allora il suono che
noi sentiamo e l'impatto dei due corpi
il plettro che viene chiamata exciter e
la corda che viene chiamato risuonatore
limoges è un po la stessa cosa dove
tutte le vibrazioni che che io creo
quando suono l'oggetto in questione
vengono usate come ex ai 3 vanno ad
eccitare un modello appunto un suonatore
che viene simulato nell'app quindi io
posso donare a questo oggetto qui le
proprietà acustiche di una corda per
esempio di una pelle eccetera citato il
modello dell'accordo
leggero il suono
però diciamo questo non è ancora musica
il bello è da cambiare le note cambiare
i suoni e quindi c'è la seconda parte
che si chiama l'attacco ecco quindi non
faccio un piccolo demo adesso perché è
più facile mostrarla che spiegarla
allora io scelgo un suono c'è questione
ad esempio una bella cassa ecco qui è
bella casa io insegno ora al mio nuovo
strumento che questo mappamondo il segno
a diciamo riconosce un certo gesto gli
dico senti questo gesto qui il mio
pollice che batte in questa zona buona
più o meno potrebbe essere associato al
suono della cassa il si vede il secondo
gest per esempio un rullante invece la
socia della mia unghia che questa
etichetta in questa zona che ora il
software riesce in tempo reale a capire
che gesto faccio io posso aggiungere
altri gesti facciamo insieme umberto
gesto dovrà posso tamburellare
adesso appena costruito nel mio piccolo
strumento del mappamondo cassa
quindi diciamo che è un po meta
strumento no uno strumento per creare
strumenti ecco allora in questi anni
abbiamo diciamo abbiamo collaborato con
tanti artisti abbiamo lanciato il
prodotto in novembre è uno dei dei vari
lì siamo progetti quello che mi sta
forse più a cuore è una collaborazione
con rodrigo e gabriele che una stanza e
conoscete sono sono un duo di
chitarristi americani diventato famoso
anche per aver fatto una parte della
colonna sonora di breaking bad serie
americana
e i pirati dei caraibi altre cose e poi
con altri artisti con imogen heap che
come sapete da sempre appassionata nuove
tecnologie
siamo già iniziato molto prima
e allora adesso io accendere un piccolo
video un minuto di
di una collaborazione artistica che ho
fatto con un duo inglese si chiamano
plaid dove tutti i suoni che sentite
sono stati fatti tramite questa
tecnologia
no
una parte delle grazie grazie
allora dopo un anno dal lancio del primo
prodotto ci siamo detti ok adesso
sarebbe bellissimo a cercare di fare di
fare un nuovo prodotto che appunto
basato sulla stessa tecnologia però per
lo scopo in verità di democratizzare
ancora di più e la musica di aiutare
bambini e adulti che non che non sono
ancora musicisti che vogliono
approcciarsi alla musica per la prima
volta a fare questa esperienza insomma
quindi abbiamo e stiamo per l'acciaio
abbiamo pronta una nuova versione ecco
di queste venzione magis play dove
l'idea appunto quella di facilitare
leggiamo questa creazione musicale
quindi ci sono varie app dove posso
inizio crearmi le melodie prima oppure
scaricare varie canzoni e siamo a
suonarla usando questa tecnologia di cui
abbiamo parlato e abbiamo dato uno dei
primi prototipi a un bambino di 10 anni
mio amico diego di londra che ci hanno
dato questo video che vi faccio vedere
a
un altro dire abruzzo possiamo dare un
altro vita allora da questo sono io con
il coro drigo di cui abbiamo parlato
prima
altro fisco la piccola gag
grazie grazie